[Music]
welcome to the fifth edition of
spectator tv
if you missed any of the previous four
you can catch up in full on our youtube
channel
today we have a great show for you i'll
be speaking to oxford's
sunitra gupta the woman whose
coronavirus model
was one of the few scientific studies
countering the wisdom or otherwise
of imperial college london back in march
i'd also be speaking to claire foxx
former brexit party
mep and founder of the institute of
ideas
about whether or not our public
institutions
have too much groupthink but before we
start a quick reminder that if you enjoy
what we're doing here
then you should take a subscription to
the spectator
you can get a free month's digital
subscription
by going to spectator.co.uk forward
slash trial
that's spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash trial that will give you
full access to all
of our articles podcasts and newsletters
as well as
instant delivery of the magazine via the
spectator app
each week now if you like it after the
free month it'll be 9.99 a month
thereafter
to take out this offer now click the i
button in the top right hand corner
of this youtube video or go as i say
again
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash
trial now on to the main event
a long winter ahead of us not game of
thrones but the words of the chief
medical officer chris whittie
at wednesday's coronavirus briefing but
is it being made longer by
too narrow an interpretation of the data
let's have a breakdown of the latest
convict situation in the country i'm
joined by
kate andreas she's perspective as
economics correspondent
but she also edits the spectators daily
covert
19 update it's a must read for anyone
who's interested
in the pandemic situation in the uk and
abroad
kate the stage is yours thanks andrew
so from the slide that you can see here
there's
basically no dispute that infection
rates have been going up in the uk
certainly over the course of last month
in september
and this just due to an increase in
testing the percentage of those tests
coming back positive has increased as
well
so we know infection rates are going up
and last monday as we discussed on
spectator
tv uh later in the week we saw that sir
patrick valens had put forward a
scenario in a press conference to the
public notably with no politician on
stage
suggesting that if cases were to double
every seven days we could be looking at
near 50 000 cases
by the 13th of october now it was
especially notable that no
other scenarios were put forward valence
was adamant that this wasn't a
prediction but we didn't get to see the
other scenarios that could be considered
and
this was especially strange because if
we look to countries like
france and spain and the trajectory that
they're on that we have been told that
the uk was very likely to be on
for weeks if not months you can see that
it's much
lower there than it was in the scenario
that balance laid out
well we've had 10 days now to see where
the uk data is gone
and this is what's actually happened now
it's not to say that it's all good news
as you can note there
the uk might be slightly ahead of france
in terms of its trajectory but it is
nowhere near the daily infection rates
that valence
laid out in his slide today october 1st
we have 6914
new cases that's a fall of 194 cases
from yesterday still
the prime minister brought in new
restrictions last week uh
this included a curfew for hospitality a
10 p.m curfew on pubs
restaurants and bars he also very
notably told office workers that if they
could work from home
they should work from home now i think
it's important that we go back to when
the first lockdown began
and back then what the public decided to
do was well ahead
of where the government was on actually
bringing in laws and restrictions
and guidance as you can see from this
chart for people dining out going to
restaurants
people flocked away from restaurants
long before the government actually made
that
mandatory so what's happened since boris
johnson last week brought in this 10 p.m
curfew and titan restrictions
as you can see here andrew restrictions
have not put people off
going to restaurants yes there has been
a small dip but it basically takes us
back down
to before the government's eat out to
help out scheme that big spike in august
was when people were actually being
subsidized to eat out so now we're back
to
to pre-eat out to help out levels but
people are still going out
they're still enjoying their lunches and
dinners outside of their homes
notably with travel trends as well uh
before
the first lockdown back in march you can
see that the huge dip is already coming
people are
staying away from their offices they're
staying away from unnecessary travel
they're staying indoors
now you can see these mobility trends
have completely reversed and
yes again a small dip since last week
when the prime minister suggested that
if you can work from home you can but
this
this shows that people are still
commuting they're still going to the
office they're still going out
and of course now employers are allowed
to um they have more control
over whether or not their employees are
coming in so i'm sure the change in
guidance from march to now
has also made a difference
and as well with schools it to to be
fair to the government they have never
suggested that you should be taking your
child out of school now
quite the opposite they're insistent
that children do go but the public
was keeping their kids at home at the
height of lockdown it seems at the
moment we haven't really seen any change
to that and i don't think it would be a
stretch to say that
the difference between the first
lockdown and how the public reacted
despite guidance
and and how they're reacting now with
guidance
is an important one and it suggests that
we've had a change in attitude as to how
we treat this virus
the number of deaths is going up you can
you can see
at the end of this chart it is starting
to rise
but perhaps as the chancellor said the
public is starting to think that we have
to learn
to live with this virus and to do so
without fear they may be
weighing their own risks and making
their own assessments about how
dangerous it is
and it's not at all to say that it is
the same as plural pneumonia
in fact if you get a very bad case of
flu pneumonia or coven 19
you could die from it but i think
looking at these charts now
many people are starting to think that
there are many risks
to getting a different virus to getting
into an accident
and perhaps the way that they treat kova
19
the second time round now falls into
that category
of other viruses and other accidents as
opposed to being
truly unique and i think you're starting
to see that reflected in the polls
we're told constantly that the polls
should support the government when they
do local lockdowns when they bring in
restrictions in fact the public often
wants
the government to go further but we got
this poll over the weekend
asking the public what they thought the
greatest problem for the country would
be
over the next 12 months and you can see
the impact on public health of coven 19
at 42
quite high throughout the first lockdown
over the summer coven 19 was very much
at the top of the public's
concerns and agenda but now for the
first time we're seeing the economy is
actually
weighing on the public's minds more not
by much but it has
inched up and made that difference which
perhaps explains
why we're seeing different trends this
time around
um so that's my update for you andrew i
think it's very clear that the public's
reaction
so far is different to the first
lockdown and that the scenario laid out
by patrick valens at this point anyway
we have not come anything close to
now all remains to be seen if these
winter months get particularly
difficult if infection rates soar you
would suspect that the public's behavior
would change but at the moment
it seems like they're willing to wait
and see what happens with infections and
particularly hospitalizations and deaths
before they go back indoors okay okay
thanks for that
let's talk now to the professor of
theoretical epidemiology at the
university of oxford
uh sinetra gupta welcome to the show
professor
i'm looking at the seven-day moving
average of new cases
uh it's now 6220
a week ago it was 4501
so it's not doubling it's rising by
under forty percent
in spain and france daily cases higher
than they are in britain
but they're flattening at around twelve
thousand uh there was no
movement in france in the past week on
daily cases and in spain there was a
slight drop
i would suggest to you but you know so
much more than i do than this
that it's inconceivable that we will get
to 50 000 cases a day
as professor whitty has said within two
weeks
inconceivable am i wrong um i would tend
to agree with you
i mean what we have here are a set of
scenarios
and what we ought to be thinking about
is
what is probable what's possible what's
unlikely
and the only way we can do that is by
understanding the logic behind
these projections or whatever they're
called
not predictions apparently so you know
you look at that
someone stands up and says it's doubling
and
if it doubles in this way then
you know just do the math or do the math
and you'll get to these extraordinary
numbers
and you know if you get stuck in the oh
yeah true if you do the math
it does go that way then you miss out on
that vital component which is
why would it do that in the first place
and so if you start to think about why
would it do that
then you realize that that sort of
thinking
you know if there's any logic to it at
all it
applies to an epidemic that's just
taking off
where everyone's susceptible and ready
available for infection and as far as we
know that is
not the case in
many of these countries certainly not in
the uk
so that's the first thing to note now we
don't know
exactly how many people are at the
moment
immune or not available for infection
because we thought we'd be able to find
this out by doing these
antibody tests but as it turns out this
situation
is a bit more complicated than that so
the zero positivity in other words how
many people have antibodies
is not a very good indication of how
many people are immune
so given that and given the
extraordinary or
quite wide heterogeneity in numbers
who have antibodies or proportions who
have antibodies
it's quite difficult to make firm
predictions
about where we're going but at the
moment
what we're seeing is not is very much in
line
with what happens to any other infection
like
around this time of the year in other
words everything goes up flu goes up
pneumococcal pneumonia goes up there are
a thousand people
a week dying of flu and pneumonia at the
moment so these
so the context is very important as is
an understanding a very basic
understanding of the dynamics
of these infections well you mentioned
that number dying of flu the seven day
moving average from
covert deaths to sporting at the moment
which is a lot less
but you see to to someone like me who
can do the arithmetic
that is has no medical expertise
whatsoever
i would come to the conclusion that we
were sort of false prospectus
intentionally
these figures were put to us with the
scientists being complicit
and the politicians suffering up the
ground for new lockdown measures
what would be wrong with that conclusion
well it's not
for me to say what the intention of the
scientists or
the politicians um what they are
um all i can say is that i think
they should think very very carefully
about the costs of lockdown
and it's not just i think we should get
away from just talking about the economy
because people tend to separate the
economy
from the impact on lives so the economy
is not just this sort of
external thing that we have to attend to
and which we can sort of ignore and
and continue down this kind of narrow
track of trying to keep covid under
control what happens
as we try to do that to other public
health issues
and the economy insofar as that affects
the lives and we're talking about life
and death we're talking
particularly if we start to broaden our
perspective from outside
the uk to the world which is i think as
international
citizens we should do we're talking
about people dying of hunger
so the economy is not sort of this
external thing that we don't need to
worry about
um it's about lives against lives and
i think that's something that's
completely
or it's not obvious in the conversations
around
the control of this virus that have been
occurring since the very beginning the
policy response
when the pandemic started to take off
was locked down
and many people thought at the time we
don't really know what's going to happen
it's a mystery
it's uncharted territory it's probably
the right thing to do that was the
public opinion but here we are now six
months in
september and the policy response to
rising cases
is still various varieties of lockdown
is that the right policy response i
don't think so
i think lockdown simply delays
things it doesn't solve the problem at
all it just delays it
and as you say right in march maybe you
know you could make the case
that we needed to buy some time so you
know let's go into the lockdown
we can afford maybe a month of lockdown
why not do that maybe you know that a
case could be made for that
although personally i was worried right
at the outset about the effects of
lockdown but you know
i think one could make a case for it uh
particularly given the sort of worst
case scenario that the imperial
college model had had presented um
but it is very clear you don't have to
have a very
uh you know sophisticated understanding
of the dynamics
of this disease um that it
to to appreciate that locking things
down can only delay it
delay its course so and if
that were if it would possible do that
without any other costs then
sure carry on locking down but it's
patently obvious that you cannot do that
that there are profound
costs and there these costs are just
mounting
so sorry that's fine
what did you make of a cake pointing
the public opinion was perhaps moving in
a direction that
maybe we now need just to learn to live
with this
not that it means uh everything back to
normal or anything like that
but that we've got to accept is going to
be around for some time
and rather than lockdowns or extreme
measures we should learn
to live with it would that be a
sensible response i think that's a very
sensible response and that's what should
have been
made available to the as an option or as
the
most likely course again
right from the outset because that is
what it was likely to happen
um with a virus of this
ilk so what's most likely to happen
and desirable is that it settles down to
what we call an
endemic equilibrium such as we enjoy
with influenza with pneumococcal
the bugs that cause pneumonia and a
variety of other pathogens
we live at an endemic equilibrium with
them
and live lives normally and accept the
deaths that they cause
because you know that's what society is
about it's about
optimizing on this really quite complex
landscape of risks
and weighing the costs and benefits to
arrive
at a solution that is the best thing
for everybody when you uh put these
points to the prime minister what did he
say
uh nothing but then he has responded
since then no clearly he didn't listen
to you did he
he hasn't since then uh responded in in
terms that suggest he doesn't agree with
what we propose as a strategy
which is that we allow the virus to
reach that endemic equilibrium
but meanwhile um protect those who are
acceptable to death and
uh you know try and hasten that moment
where it becomes the same as flu
which may have already happened we don't
know but
to try and get there the best thing to
do is to allow it to circulate
and protect the vulnerable people and
then once it gets reaches that
endemic equilibrium life can return
to normal there's it doesn't have to go
to some new normal
we can go back to the old normal maybe
we can learn a few things
from the experiment but
uh fraser
is the prime minister being held hostage
by his two
senior scientific advisors
i don't think so i actually think that
when he had professor gupta in
the weekend before last and other people
of her persuasion
he was trying at least to listen to
other voices now
since then sure he hasn't said that he
agrees with her
or doesn't disagrees with the swedish
approach
but we haven't had too much in the way
of restrictions
when i heard earlier this week that
we're going to get another boris johnson
and patrick valence press conference i
was all braced for
sharper lockdown measures the same as i
was on tuesday last week
in both cases they didn't um emerge
i think he's in a position now where he
has created some space
to allow himself to have a look at the
data
is it going to settle is it going to
look at the balance projections
if it isn't following the balance
trajectory in the way that cater showed
us it isn't
then we don't need to proceed with more
national
lock down measures so my sense is that
in listening to dissenting voices and
also recently he's asked him
and patrick vance and chris woody to
meet his cabinet every week this is a
new development
and expose them to their questioning so
i think he is now creating space
where you can say okay gentlemen i've
heard you but i've got to consider
cancer deaths the economy public health
in general
and i think on balance i'm not going to
implement
lockdowns would you recommend james we
know the tory backbenchers have been
unhappy they got some concessions they
they the rebellion was kind of bought
off
but i would suggest that when we get to
the middle of october
and it's clear we are nowhere near 50
000 cases a day
that a lot of tory mps are going to be
saying what are we playing now
why are we doing this uh when will the
government get a grip
and i think the other issue andrew is
the virus is becoming more
regional that's something that you know
patrick balance and chris whitty
and boris johnson were all talking about
at the press conference on wednesday
and if you look at those figures that
they published about hospital admissions
the infection rates in various parts of
the country you see that in the east of
england
in the south west and the south east the
virus is in the words of one minister
as flat as a pancake it's not going up
now the north east is bad the northwest
is also
difficult and troublesome largely
because of the situation on merseyside
and in liverpool in particular
but i think what we're going to see in
the next few weeks is you're going to
see
mps from those parts of the country
saying come on we haven't got we've got
hardly any covered here at all
we don't need these restrictions they're
killing local businesses
you need to ease things up and i think
this is
one of the big battle that is to come
you know one of the more um
dovish cabinet ministers who wants more
restrictions said to me look
uh after the imperial numbers came out
look you know the virus is not
increasing as fast as i expected
but that's because we've changed the
national attitude but you know by
reminding people of a dangerous places
now that's one view
the view of others in government is look
we are following france and spain
and french and spanish experience
suggests that the second spike is just
not the same as the first spike
and this idea that it is the second wave
is going to be bigger than the first
wave which some people in downing street
are convinced of
is is for the birds and so it's time to
think about the economy
and the consequences as professor gupta
said for all of these other health
questions
of a society that is uh not operating at
full capacity
okay just to finish up on this the
professor made a wider point about the
impact of the economy
uh and that isn't just an economic
matter uh
it is social and health as well but
david smith was writing in the sunday
times that in
his he believed that by the end of
september
the british economy economy will only be
about
five percent smaller than it was in
february
which would be an amazing return but
that these new restrictions coming in
the new work at home the ten o'clock uh
curfew and all the rest
meant that rather than making up that
final five percent in
the last three months of this year first
couple of months of next year
we'll limp into the fourth quarter we'll
stagnate in the months ahead
and basically we blow in getting the
economy back to normal
exactly haldane said something very
similar
recently uh in in one of his speeches
and
i think there's a real sense and the
data is showing it that the uk economy
is rebounding
the question is whether or not you think
a v-shaped recovery
tails off at the very end and to your
point andrew i think there's real
concern especially if we get more
restrictions
come the winter months to the point
where businesses do really start to
buckle and really start to feel it
that we will all be living uh we'll all
be living a bit poorer
and we'll all be slightly worse off for
quite a long time
the scenarios from the big hitters are
have already changed to show that they
think recovery is going to take
longer than they originally thought and
that's because in these scenarios
they don't predict for for new measures
that could come in and the fact that
restrictions came in so quickly in early
autumn suggest that it really could take
some time
to get back to pre-cover growth levels
all right let's move on viewers if
you've got questions for professor gupta
or any of our team here
send them to spectator tv at spectator
dot
co dot uk and we'll put them to the
professor
now good charles moore former editor of
the daily telegraph
the sunday telegraph and indeed the most
important position of all the spectator
could have become the new chairman of
the bbc
he's a vocal critic of the license fee
indeed he took his principles all the
way to court in 2010
his appointment could come hand in hand
with paul dicker former
editor of the daily mail taking the lead
at ofcom the media regulator which also
regulates the bbc with a kind of double
whammy for anti-people there is it time
for these
kind of changes douglas murray argues
yes in this week's spectator
but i'm not joined by claire fox she's
founder of the institute of ideas former
brexit party mep she's a frequent
contributor to bbc shows like the morrow
maze i mean claire many people will see
this is just the juries putting their
mates
into um nice prestigious positions
actually many people just saw it as them
trolling everybody because the reaction
as douglas murray
makes clear was that there was an
absolute meltdown from all sorts of
quarters i think douglas
and quotes one of my favorite ones which
was alan rusbridger former editor of the
uh guardian who now runs in oxford
college
basically complaining about an autocracy
and a government putting their friends
in high places with no sense of irony at
all
uh that he had been appointed to an
oxford college or he'd been the editor
of guardian and he was
just part of a previous era but you know
i
i still can't believe that this is going
to actually happen
and it's sort of enjoyable and good fun
and
but i think there's a more serious and
important point here
and you know any government might want
to appoint people
into positions of power and influence
but i think that the greater issue is
that
whilst the conservatives won a massive
majority at the last election it is true
that the institutions in this country
and we've seen this
very explicitly in the last four years
really since brexit
have a particular type of people at
their health
and it's not that they're labor people
they're not it's not a party
point actually a lot of the maturities
there's a lot of tories
who are metropolitan liberals on a
massive number of issues it's not
a kind of party point it's a kind of
world view that sees things in a
particular way
and in that sense i think that there's
been a kind of institutional capture
it's not exactly gramsci in march
through the institutions but it feels
like that
and you do feel as though everybody who
runs everything from the national trust
to the british
museum to the to the bbc to every
institution has a particular way of
looking at the world
and therefore are affronted by world
views that don't
uh coincide with their own and i mean
we've just been listening to professor
gupta she's been
slightly on the receiving end of this
and it's like dare one descent
on anything and feel the full wrath of a
particular institutional worldview
so i hope we can shake things up this
way
i'd like to see it up one
is is one way putting bulls into china
shops is not shaking things up
well i mean i can understand that the
tories have watched labour put its
people in
to positions of importance you know tony
blair for
gavin davis is chairman of the bbc greg
dyke as director general
of the bbc both were staunch labor
people greg
donated to the labour party gavin davis
was a sort of tony
to to tony cronin i get all that they
may want their own people but it's the
kind of people
i'm i mean putting paul dicker into
ofcom
this is the digital age ofcom's big job
now
is regulating uh digital uh
communications uh paul is an old steam
engine newspaper man
with ink in uh in his fingernails
putting charles murray into the bbc
as chairman this is someone that doesn't
even watch any television
uh probably doesn't even know how to
switch one on
or switch one off yeah so i think that's
because that's just
vandalism is it not yeah well that's the
danger with it it's um you know that
that all the time there's a feeling that
politics
amounts to nothing more than tit for tat
you know even with something like
council culture the people who hate
council culture decide to cancel the
councillors
and in this instance it's a bit that's
why i started off saying it's a bit like
trolling you know it's kind of
you add your people in we'll have our
people in i was simply just trying to
describe what the issue was
and i can understand the attempt to
shake it
up but i don't i agree with you that
just putting place
men or women in you know just shaking it
up by having personnel that will annoy
everyone isn't really the point and i
think that actually douglas
uh money makes it makes this very clear
that there's there's more profound
cultural questions here on the one hand
it's interesting to see the conservative
government making an attempt
at entering into this cultural arena
which i think is underestimated i think
that
you know this arena of political
capture in the cultural sense is
something that everybody should be
concerned about because it has a
profound impact on the kind of news we
get on the kind of media we have
and the kind of institutions we have but
i would actually
say that what we need to do is not just
put in different people
but actually have a big discussion about
what the attitudes within those
organizations are
i mean and they just respect yourself i
do but what's
interesting is the impact that the
announcement that you were about to
to be involved in another tv venture has
also
sent shock waves too and when i talk
about shaking things up that's what i
mean
i mean there is a complacency in these
institutions
that there's only one way to view the
world and
look at the shock that people got when
for example in the eu referendum people
didn't go along with things
there is a kind of assumption of
we know best and an outlook that you
dare not challenge
and so i think that what we need is a
shake-up i hope it goes beyond
poor day career off-camera making any
comments on that
if that's what it amounts to it's
immature and childish
to be frank it won't make any difference
it's been enjoyable i
i also think it is worth noting that's a
lot of well-known commentators said
things like if charles moore becomes the
head of the bbc
everybody at the bbc will leave without
also noticing
that that indicated a kind of group
thing gone mad you know
what you're admitting is that people all
think with the same way and they don't
want somebody different
in and i i i do think that these things
impact our democracy because there is a
sense in which now people
do not feel that their views are
represented in the media they do
feel as though there is a one-tone
conversation
i think in relation to the coronavirus
issue
there is a you know people about the
stuffing knocked out of them the people
in hartlepool and
and the northeast are not rejoicing at
the impact as
as professor gupta has said which is the
economy isn't just some
abstract notion it will destroy the
livelihoods of the people in the
northeast
that they've overreacted in this way
that should be discussed without you
being called a cove idiot
you know without being dismissed as some
sort of flat earther who's an
anti-vaxxer
and so i just would appreciate that we
understand that institutions run by
people who have
group think at their core and only can
see things in one particular way
has been incredibly destructive over
trust in institutions in democracy
and in people in authority and i would
like it to change
so i just i don't mind the odd bit of
stirring
but it's not sufficient and a more
profound
uh discussion is required all right
frieza you
putting aside the two personalities uh
involved which uh you do think were kind
of uh
brought up to scale the horse seasons in
some ways
you could argue that ten years of tory
government
they've been actually rather slow on
some of these appointments the the
the these kind of appointments and the
the great public institutions
are still largely dominated by
the center left by sort of playwright
consensus
and there aren't that many tories in
that position and nor
did mr cameron or mrs may in the brief
time she had
make much of a difference there would
that be true i think it is i just think
victories really aren't really playing
this game
and i mean i think it's all like
hilarious let's suggest paul dagor and
george of ofcom
lets everybody go wild but um
is that really going to implement change
and also in the cameron years aren't
remember
listening to the cameroons in 2010
looking great we've now won an election
so now
we're going to reverse all of this
gordon brown gerrymandering of the
charities the fifth columnist forever
labour party
and we're going to neutralize them not
get our around people in but neutralize
them
and none of that really happened they
got very excited when i think they
got the historian andrew roberts onto
the board of the national portrait
gallery
and i think that was about the peak of
the tory achievements in this so
it's it's just a low-grade game really
and i'm afraid to say that
recently there was nothing that makes me
think but they're really serious about
trying to restore neutrality to this but
the other thing is if it is just
chamocracy if it is let's let's get our
people just to annoy the other side
i'm afraid to say that most tourists i
think ought to be condemning that just
as much as they would
it was a labour party taking overt
sympathizers
and it kind of gauche in a way and again
suggest a fundamental
unseriousness okay that's what do you
think out there
plenty of questions uh send them to
spectator tv
spectator dot co dot uk you're watching
the week in 60 minutes
coming to you from spectator tv thanks
again to our sponsor
uh the nat west group for supporting
this broadcast now
the us election the presidential debate
earlier this week was a disgrace viewers
will have seen the low lights
if not you can catch up on them with the
spectator tv us election special from
wednesday night it's up on youtube
we'll have a montage there and analysis
but is it a taste
of things to come the outcome of this
november's election is likely to be more
fraught than bush v
gore in 2000 our cover piece this week
explains exactly why and i'm joined now
by matt purple
senior editor of the american
conservative and he penned that cup of
peace
matt welcome i want to come on to uh
some of the things that might happen on
on election day and in the immediate
aftermath you were writing about them
but i want to put something more broadly
to you for your reaction
i get the sense of the trump campaigns
in real trouble now
he was in trouble before went into the
debate uh
and it's in trouble more trouble coming
out of that debate
and a lot of them are not sure how
they're going to get this show back on
the road
and that he's probably going to lose
yeah i mean it really was the chernobyl
of debates it was absolutely a disgrace
like you were saying before it
you know we have never seen anything
even remotely close to that in american
history and i think
that the crazy thing about it is that
the president reportedly walked off the
stage thinking he had done a good job
you know patting himself on the back and
he'd really stuck it to joe biden
and it took his advisors going to him
and telling him no you really
you went on too hot like you came on too
strong
you got to dial it back last time and so
i i think that
draws in a problem here which is that
trump is so willful
and he's so determined to be donald
trump he can't really be anything else
he can't change his stripes
that you know if you have to alter your
course if you have to come off as a
little bit more civil in the next debate
or try to correct your errors
trump is not somebody who corrects his
errors he is somebody who declares
victory even when he's in defeat
uh he's somebody who rarely ever
apologizes for anything so
his handlers are going to be struggling
with that and i think
you know biden has been ahead
consistently in the polls
the one thin read of hope that trump
voters or trump's people have hung on to
is that 2016 situation where an awful
lot of people didn't
tell pollsters they were voting for
donald trump because they were
embarrassed they were a bit sheepish
about it
uh there was kind of this invisible man
factor that came back and propelled him
over the edge just at the end or over
the top just at the end
and everyone is on on the right is
crossing their fingers and hoping that's
going to happen again this time
the problem is you know you still need
to win over independent voters you still
need to bring back
some of those uh catholics and the
de-industrialized rust belt states that
you won last time around you need to
to reel in some political independence
uh
how many undecided voters watched that
nuclear storm and thought oh
yeah i really got a good show of the
candidates there i mean i was really
able to
discern who i'm going to vote for i
really learned something
uh nobody at all if anything they're
just going to be repelled by donald
trump
if you stand back a bit and think all
right what's mr trump got going for him
he's probably got the economy going
forward he pulls better than mr biden
on that he's actually had too many
people's surprises some reasonable
foreign policy
policy successes his hard line with
china is the new normal in
in washington now even mr biden who used
to cozy up to the chinese was attacking
the
china in in the debate um
he's brought offers a remarkable feat of
the uae
and uh bahrain orbiting diplomatic
relations with israel
uh and a lot more of these gulf states
are going to follow
but i would suggest this problem is that
rather than talking about these things
or bringing these sort of things to the
fore
which would make them seem a bit more
presidential if that's possible
this bluster this heckling this
hectoring
is all people see and the noise obscures
any of the substance he made his own
temperament the issue
which i think was the problem he made
his disposition the issue
and uh the public liked that to an
extent in 2016
they were in a very rebellious mood uh
but he was also running against a very
a wildly unpopular democratic candidate
a candidate who
from the beginning like from the time
she entered the democratic primary all
the way back in 2015
had a massive trust deficit in the polls
people did not like her
he's running against somebody this time
around who's genuinely more likable
you know i think you can present a
better contrast who comes off that way
i think the answers that joe biden gives
that the debates are going to be weaker
than hillary clinton's but i think
overall he's a better package for
independent voters and
the problem is if trump comes off in
that boorish manner if he draws all that
attention to
you know on to himself well first of all
you're on the risk that the public is
not in quite as rebellious a mood this
time around
second of all you run the risk of you're
the incumbent you know you don't just
get to
to you know punch people around you
don't just get to to pump your fists in
the air
you have a record to defend you're
supposed to be containing some of these
problems you're supposed to be pointing
to things that you were able to
accomplish
not just absolutely flame throwing your
opponent which is what he came off into
and also behaving with some kind of
presidential decorum i
remember this isn't he's no longer just
the host of the apprentice he is now the
president of the united states
and inevitably is going to get judged
with a different prism or through a
different prism i think because of that
and yeah it you know it i think it
called attention to the worst of donald
trump i don't think that biden
necessarily rose above it
i don't think that you can call that a
decisive win for joe biden per se
uh i i think it was just you know
negative hellfire all around and trump
ended up getting burned the most
i wonder if the the republicans are
right
to put so much faith in the polls being
wrong i mean the polls will always be
wrong
to some extent but this time around they
they've made a number of changes they're
correcting for education
which they didn't do before they uh
because education had never been a huge
factor in how
people voted in 2016 it was a huge
factor
in how people voted and they're
correcting for that they've brought in
they're more unknown college educated
those who have
left high school or even didn't leave
high school
with a diploma there are fewer
undecideds now many fewer
than there were the last time mr biden
has twice the lead among women than
hillary clinton had
in pennsylvania which mr trump has to
win
mr biden's rocking it in philadelphia
he's sweeping the cybers as well
particularly with the soccer moms and so
on but he's holding up in the western
counties as well
which is what got mr trump
the victory last time around and when
you look at
all that dustin pennsylvania and the
plenty of others i would suggest
that i think donald trump realizes he's
going to lose
he's certainly going to lose the popular
vote and he will probably man lose the
electoral college vote
so he's already planning the ground for
that he's going to say
that i won on the day i won by the
people who turned up to vote the honest
way the old american way
all these votes that have since come in
in the following week
are fraudulent they're fixed you can't
count on them
i still won that will be a
constitutional crisis will it not
it could be yeah if biden doesn't win in
an absolute crushing landslide or you
should say trump doesn't win an absolute
crushing landslide
it could be and you know this gets back
to what i said in my piece which is that
uh you know we we americans like to
follow to file lawsuits well we've been
filing them over this election already
there are more than 300 lawsuits that
have already been filed even before
voting starts
most of them by republicans most of them
worried about the mail in balloting they
do have some reason to be concerned
uh during new york's primary elections
for example back in june
uh there was a lot of mail-in balance we
have more mail-in ballots than usual
right now because of the coronavirus so
they're encouraging people to mail their
ballots in rather than going to polling
places
and in new york's primary there ended up
being real chaos afterwards it took them
weeks to determine the winner
uh they ended up accidentally throwing
out a bunch of ballots
a number of ballots that they shouldn't
have that they then had to reel back in
it is not it did not give confidence in
our electoral system and
there are partisans on both sides who
are lawyering up
uh who are extremely polarized to an
almost existential degree you know who
think that if the republicans or
democrats get elected this time around
it's not just going to be bad it's going
to mean the end of that that really is
that the peated political climate in the
united states we're dealing with
and who think okay we're going to fight
this as far as we possibly can we're
going to take it as far as we can
and then into all of this comes the
death of a supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg
taking the supreme court down to an uh
and even
eight justices so it could the high
court could split evenly if it comes all
the way up to that
uh in that case it wouldn't be like in
the year 2000 when
the supreme court determined by a 5-4
vote the winner of that election that
you know gave it to george w
bush and you could end up with a
situation where
you have to go back to the lower courts
but there's multiple lawsuits multiple
lower courts
uh different standards are applied in
different states
that creates confusion it allows both
sides to declare victory and suddenly
we are in the likes of a constitutional
crisis that we have never seen before
well in the year 2000 there was only
florida really in contention
in 1876 there were four states in
contention
naturally including florida it almost
seems to be there
and uh it took them four three months
to resolve these four states sent
different delegates
of electors one for toons and the
democrat one for rutherford hayes the
republican
and they sent teams of both to support
them and it was only resolved with 56
hours to go
and in these days the inauguration was
until march it's now
in the constitution that it's on january
the 20th it could be a very
given mad final question to to you on
this given
the febrile mood in so many american
cities
at the moment all these people walking
around with automatic rifles and so i
mean only in america
could you see that um it
it seems to me it's a dangerous time for
the united states
and uh what happens if in that 11 week
period president z decides it's time to
make a move in taiwan
or president putin decides let's put the
screws on latvia
who's going to be running the country
yeah well semi-automatic rifles andrew
let's not go too crazy here but it's
right it's it's a very fraught
potentially violent situation
and i actually said 1888 election on the
podcast this morning
so you're right it was 1876.
the subtext of that is that samuel
tilden the candidate who ultimately lost
rutherford b hayes was in the white
house his supporters never let them
forget it they they
always claimed that he was robbed they
never let go of it
and so you had this situation over the
next four years where there was
legitimate
tension you know where there is an
illegitimate president in the minds of a
lot of people
and trump is already illegitimate in the
minds of a lot of people on the left
they don't think that he won fair and
square he snuck in with the minority of
the popular vote
uh you know stuck by in the electoral
college and
so you're dealing suddenly with this
question of presidential legitimacy
of what happens if even if you do manage
to get a winner in there
even if you do manage to have somebody
declared what if
half the country doesn't accept it what
if they do turn to violence in the
streets what if
you know that is the the match that
lights up the powder keg and
i i really don't know i i grew up in a
time in america the 1990s when we seemed
to be totally stable you know the soviet
union had fallen
uh we were king of the the hill people
were talking about a unipolar world and
the united states could do whatever
we wanted and everybody was looking up
to us and now suddenly
uh we're that problem nation you know
we're that nation over a barrel and
uh i think we can get out of it there's
no reason to think that we can't our
history has been much more fraud and
violent than a lot of people sometimes
think you know we've
we've kind of been here before uh but
but certainly
enormous challenges and and dark times
in america potentially
going forward that election of 1876
resulted in the compromise of 1877
which gave rutherford hayes the white
house but it gave to the racists and the
segregationist the south
and after that compromise of 1877 there
was not a fair election
for blacks in the south until 1968.
there was a big price to pay i just
wonder what it will be this time
let's move on to your questions we've
got one from john prescott i'm not sure
it's the john prescott but uh
it's john prescott to professor gupta
yeah interesting question which key
metric should we be
using to see how bad the covet situation
is
well certainly we shouldn't be looking
at cases
there are all sorts of problems
associated with
testing positive what that actually
means does it mean a person is
infected infectious or simply has some
residual
um bits of virus in their throat or
laser pharynx or
up their nose wherever they take it from
um
deaths is always good you can't argue
with deaths
um but the other so i think we should be
looking at deaths
very uh but the other important point
yeah
is that we should be looking at deaths
and even cases where should we be able
to measure them correctly and
see contextualize them against the
amount of testing that's being done eve
all of these
should be placed benchmarked against
what is happening
with other infections other respiratory
infections in particular
what's happening with flu what's
happening with pneumococcal pneumonia
until we place it in the context of
these other infections
we we tend to have to get this sort of
blinkered
sort of our viewpoint is very restricted
james here's one for you from roger
murphy is there much sign that the
government will be prepared to reverse
some of the recent lockdown measures
if the rate of rise of cases doesn't
meet the projection
what do you think i get the impression
from your article in this week's
spectator that
mr johnson is now kind of thinking this
is the way it's going to be through the
march
yeah i think that he has got to a place
where he thinks this is where it's going
to be until the end of the winter until
spring begins on march 23rd i think the
hope of those in government who would
like to see restrictions eased up
is in 10 to 14 days is it going to be
clear
that we are nowhere near the balance
scenario
that we're in a completely different
world and therefore you can ease up i
mean the part of the problem at the
moment though
is that inside government there is no
falsifiable situation
so eg if we don't see the balance
scenario coming true those people who
advocate for restrictions
will say it was the restrictions that
did it it was
you know tightening things up with the
rule of six
it was shutting hospitality an hour
earlier it's these local lockdown
measures
and i think that is the slight problem
at the moment i think the thing i would
say is
the development today with the mayor of
middlesbrough rejecting
the government and being followed by the
mayor of particular is significant
because this is the first time
we've had real local pushback to these
local lockdowns
previously you've had as you have in
liverpool today you've had local
authorities asking the government to go
further now the mayor of leicester was a
bit all over the place but you know
given that he was caught up a ladder
during lockdown doing various things he
wasn't in a brilliant place to make the
case i mean the interesting thing about
the mayor of middlesbrough
is the speed with which he came out with
traps to say look we defy the government
on this because
we don't think this is the right
response and and interestingly
uh to put things that by professor gupta
and claire have said
his argument was that you know
destroying jobs is going to have a
devastating kind of mental health impact
as well so he was very reluctant to go
along with the measures
and i think it's an interesting question
so whether you're going to see
up to now the government has been
holding back you know about sadiq khan
in london
mayors who want more restrictions if we
end up getting pushback
then that will change the political
calculation i think here's
a question for you for is it wendy
connor says i live in the northwest and
have been in lockdown for over two
months
kimbar is really risk creating a
long-term north-south
divide over covered given how he won
the election and by that she means of
course he won because libby's red wall
in the north crumbled
it's a very interesting question i mean
boris johnson will tell you still
that leveling up is his main agenda he
wants to get but he doesn't really
acknowledge
that the lockdown will have vastly
deepened for inequalities not just
between north and south but between
rich and poor the government is in a
little bit of denial about quantifying
the damage
of lockdown uh there are calculations
showing that more people will die from
the indirect effects take of the
policies taken
they will have died from the virus
itself but ministers never quote it
it's a very one-sided debate and i'm
afraid to say i don't think
the the i think the government has
focused
very much on this um now of course when
you express it in those terms that the
northern lockdowns are putting at a
disadvantage to the south
well that will probably make the
government tempted to lock down london
the london's infection rates have been
rising a little bit and now and again
when i put this to ministers that's what
they say oh well we'll lock down london
that will be next and that will show
that it's there's no regional imbalance
but there's a whole bunch of inequality
questions that the government
simply hasn't been facing and it will
have to face them when the fruits of
those and policy decisions
come to bear clarion for you on the bbc
the government uh this is from brian
stanley the government didn't
back up roger scrutin or toby young i
think some of our viewers will
know about that case because the the
figures associated with the spectator
and bright sunlight is right the
government actually fired roger putin
from his position
he was subsequently vindicated can they
really handle the backlash from charles
muer
and uh mr daker uh is a decent question
because
this is a government famous for his
u-turns isn't it
yeah i mean uh spinelessness is is
something i could come to
associate with this moment i didn't
think that would be what i would have to
say but
i mean actually the behavior that
behavior in relation
a different government that was with
with uh roger scrutin
and toby young but you know you just
feel that you would
i wouldn't want to be trusting them to
to watch your back if they came under
too much pressure
but i think that the so so first of all
we don't know whether they'll back those
two individuals we don't even know if
those two individuals have been offered
or want the job since it happens
but i think the broader let me tell you
oh they did
well
okay right good well like well or
interesting but what i think that the
uh the question has to be though whether
they will back them up in
in a deeper sense which is to open up a
different kind of conversation i mean
what i the point that fraser's just made
about they're in
denial about what the kind of
north-south divide is i think they're in
denial about
how important this issue of of
how we think about uh the uk and british
institutions
the fury with which a lot of people have
felt about the the national trust you
know these
things are not just glib right-wing
traits as some people try and describe
them
because it goes much deeper than that
the people feel as though there are two
countries that there's a country that's
obsessed with identity politics that
obsesses over these
uh what kind of language you use whether
you're going to be accused of being
transphobic or on the one hand
or or whether you you know the whole
statues question
it's not just a superficial silly thing
this it's feeling that the institutions
of the country
no longer believe to the people who live
in the country and they do want to feel
as though
they have some stake in this and i think
that we have not seen a very good show
from a
huge majority of a conservative
government who haven't i mean do you
think the one thing that
they do is never mind putting people in
positions like this i mean
the prime minister boris johnson could
have given a a lecture
on the importance of this in the height
of the some of the
frenzy around the kind of reaction to
the terrible uh
brutal killing of george floyd but then
when the whole black lives matter thing
happens the unconscious fire situation
becoming mandated in many workplaces why
doesn't he just do a speech
a proper thing where he actually
addresses the nation instead of making
some glib comments about
the last night in the proms it just i
don't want gesture politics
from the left they annoy me when they
virtue signal
and i don't want to kind of anti-woke
gesture politics from the right
because it's equally as glib it makes a
mockery of the institutions they're
supposed to be saving
all right question uh from colin tsar
matt for you
trump lost all three debates last time
he still won
so debates matter i'm not sure though
that he didn't lose all three
last time and he certainly had huge
novelty value
uh which appealed to the the
disillusioned
yes i'm not sure he lost all three
debates certainly he didn't lose them or
at least come off the way that he did in
this last one
i'm not even going to say that he lost
it necessarily i think the way that he
presented himself right from the start
was just so
apocalyptically bad and you know people
knew they were seeing something
different
in 2016 but you'll recall when he
debated hillary clinton
there were some odd bizarre moments but
it wasn't anything like this this was
just
untrammeled trump you know this was
trump right out of the bag uh but
nonetheless
so i think that is going to turn off
people you know i've never heard voters
as shocked as they were after hearing
that i've never heard him drawing the
kind of condemnation from republicans
that he has from his own people after
that debate
but nonetheless i'm going to leave that
door open just a little bit because i
take the point and that is that
after the unsureties of 2016
after the polls were wrong and given how
utterly unconventional this president is
i'm not willing to to write him off and
i i still feel a bit of an element of
mystery here i think that
anything could still happen no it could
indeed
commentators like you and me have come
so many things rob in recent years
which you'd be quite humble about this
upcoming election though my sense
is that it is not looking good for mr
trump now and uh and he's gonna have a
hell of a job
uh to try and turn this around believe
there are two more debates
including the vice president but that
will move the dial
the two more presidential debates and
and we shall
see kate you um i think you're
you've been a registered republican but
i'm told that you
you might be thinking of voting for mr
biden this time around is that right
that is right andrew and i don't feel
good about it until i remember what the
other option is
uh ronald reagan redefined the
conservative party at the republican
party i should say
uh to be much more free-market but at
the heart of that there was a real
belief in individualism that to be
american
was a point of principle it was a set of
ethics it was
the love of your country but it didn't
matter where you came from or what body
you were born into to have that and
i fear that under donald trump the
republican party has
moved to a very anti-immigrant mindset
that it didn't have under reagan or
loved immigrants mr reagan regardless
honestly the fact that the world
wanted to come to america because it was
the city on the hill
it was deeply
i remember once he told me i said to him
you don't give any hispanic votes and he
said
the hispanics are conservatives they
just don't realize it yet
well he he he was he valued migration so
much he valued the the love that
immigrants had for their
newly adopted country and under
president trump i mean what minority
group hasn't he attacked
migrants women mexicans in particular at
the very start of the race in 2016 and
at that point i knew it was going to be
a
different republican party but i have to
echo matt i think that the
shy trump vote has only grown not to say
that the pollsters are getting it
completely wrong but i would not write
him off for what could happen
in about five weeks time but this is the
real question if you look at the way
that donald trump won in 2016 he
he clearly won the electoral college but
it was about 80 000 votes
over three crucial swing states and the
question for me has always been
is there a democratic candidate that
could win back those 80
000 votes that could increase in turn uh
that could increase uptake and voting to
make up for that
and it is my deep suspicion that joe
biden is a candidate that can do that
right from the polls anyway it's clear
the boy from scranton is winning back
pennsylvania
uh mr trump's going to have real trouble
trying to
hold on to that but we shall see only
five weeks to go james a final thought
you follow america very closely just a
quick final thought from you
so i think on the from the british
perspective here i mean there is an
intriguing element about who downing
street would prefer to win
i think over the summer down the street
began to adjust itself to abiding the
possibility of a biden presidency
they looked forward to the u.n climate
change summit and they could see how
biden made a triumph there more lightly
but i think biden's reaction and the
the the speed of frosty which he pushed
back on this internal market bill
has i think once more put those
relations under strain
all right if anybody from downing street
is watching my strong advice is
do not get involved it will end in tears
just be an observer thanks for joining
the week in 60 minutes
uh we'd love to find out what you
thought how we could improve it there is
always room for improvement send any
thoughts to spectator tv
at spectator dot co dot uk thanks to all
of our guests
great team great to have you tonight and
also thanks to our supportive sponsor of
the natwest group
and here's a special offer for our
spectator tv audience for a limited time
you can get a monthly digital
subscription to the spectator
for free yes i'm giving it away if you
subscribe at spectator
dot co dot uk forward slash trial
that'll give you access to all of our
articles even the magazine ones
our newsletters the podcasts everything
in between
and if you like it you can renew for
just 9.99
a month it's a steal a bargain and then
you can get all that at spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash trial
thank you all for watching i hope you
join us again next thursday six o'clock
london time p.m
for another the week in 60 minutes
[Laughter]
bye-bye
[Music]
you